[Musik]
unsere tägliche besser als eines der
faszinierendsten phänomene des alltags
nirgends sonst kann man so direkt die
gesetze der natur beobachten zb die
chaostheorie
obwohl die widmung gewinnt ströme und
tiefdruckgebiete auf das wetter in der
zukunft auswirken ist es dennoch
unmöglich
das wetter für eine längere zeit
vorherzusagen das liegt daran dass unser
wettersystem sehr empfindlich auf die
anfangs bedingungen reagiert ist die
windgeschwindigkeit auch nur ein kleines
bisschen schneller
oder gibt es eine unvorhergesehene
temperaturschwankungen da kann das wenig
später das wetter eines ganzen gebietes
verändern
trotzdem sind wir den letzten
jahrzehnten besser geworden die
wettervorhersage für die kommende woche
ist inzwischen genauso zuverlässig wie
die wettervorhersage für den nächsten
tag vor 30 jahren
und das können wir unter anderem zwei
dingen verdanken
zum einen haben wir inzwischen bieten
durch schnellere computer die unsere
wetter warten verarbeiten können die
exponentielle steigerung der
leistungsfähigkeit von mikrochips in den
letzten jahrzehnten erlaubt dass uns das
wetter einen immer kleineren raster
größen zu berechnen
inzwischen sind das meistens vier mal
vier kilometer zum anderen verdanken wir
die genauere wettervorhersagen dem
gewachsenen netz der messstationen
kleinere autonome warten wetter
satelliten und inzwischen auch
wetterballons mit gps sammeln wichtige
daten und übermitteln diese direkt über
das internet an zentrale server
[Musik]
leider liegt genau hier aber auch das
problem wenn wir die wettervorhersagen
weiterhin verbessern wollen
während nico schulz alle ein bis zwei
jahre für den gleichen preis doppelt so
leistungsstark werden sind
professionelle messstation und
wetterballons unglaublich teuer und
bleiben das voraussichtlich auch der
deutsche wetterdienst betreibt aktuell
rund 180 wetter warten und knapp 1800
wetterstationen in deutschland das ist
nur eine messstation für 178
quadratkilometer fläche für das aktuelle
wetter an orten an denen es keine
wetterstationen gibt werden zwischen
werte errechnet was sehr fehleranfällig
ist und für unsere wettervorhersage gilt
das gleiche wie für jedes modell
je mehr daten es gibt desto besser ist
die vorhersage
was wir also in zukunft brauchen um die
wettervorhersagen weiter zu verbessern
sind viele kleine messstationen wie
überall in deutschland verteilt sind
aber kaum etwas kosten
[Musik]
ich bin letzten zu uni münster gefahren
wo ein projektteam an genau dieser
wetterstation arbeitet die fans
mit hilfe sein duett yourself baukasten
zu umwelt messstationen
man kann damit verschiedene umwelt
stellungnahme von der temperatur über
luftfeuchtigkeit luftdruck bis zu licht
basierten phänomen wie helligkeit
beleuchtungsstärke oder uv-strahlung
mensch die fans box ist eigentlich nur
eine kleine box mit einem vereinfachten
computer und einer verbindung zum
internet
dazu kommen dann viele kleine sensoren
und schon hat man eine eigene mini
wetterstation nur zu einem viel
geringeren frei mit gerade einmal zehn
euro ist der luftdruck sensor der
teuerste sensor von allem aber können
die begünstigen sensoren denn von der
qualität her mithalten richtige
wetterstationen sind ja nicht ohne grund
zu teuer
wir vergleichen daten sozusagen zu
professionellen stationen wir können sie
angst dass der luftdruck tänzer den wir
nutzen hier der der sehr gute werte
liefert im vergleich zu hoch
professionellen sensoren wo es kaum
abweichungen gibt beim temperatur
luftfeuchte sind durch das anders die
geben tatsächlich abweichungen kann man
das feststellen
die aber auch vor allem auf das gehäuse
zurückzuführen sind also im innenbereich
sind sensoren sehr sehr gut haben eine
abweichung von unter einem grad bei im
außenbereich kann das auch schon mal
zwei grad seien auch drei jahren
insbesondere bei warmen temperaturen
wenn die sonne aufs gehäuse knallt auf
unseren jahr war immer dui do yourself
strahlenschutz knallt wird dort durchaus
wärme zu einem gewissen teil kann dieser
effekt allerdings abgefangen werden
wenn das gehäuse zb bei allen getesteten
fans boxen gleichermaßen für eine höhere
temperatur sorgt dann kann man diese
zusätzlichen gerade später wieder
herausrechnen
aber genau die luftqualität aber im
zeitplan ist ein riesenthema weltweit in
großstädten im luftqualität zu messen
denn die hängt natürlich mit der
gesundheit zusammen und das ist eines
der ziele und wird projektes auch eben
nicht mit licht basiert photonischen
sensoren luftfahrt ketten machen
neben vielen sensoren verwirklich in der
fans bot aber auch eine möglichkeit zum
lernen denn wenn die box geliefert wird
muss man sie erst einmal auf allen
einzelteilen zusammen bauen
dabei setzt man sich direkt viel
intensiver mit der thematik auseinander
und lernt etwas über microcontroller und
wenn man möchte sogar über das
programmieren
sobald die kleine wetterstation dann im
garten oder auf dem balkon aufgebaut und
an das internet angeschlossen wurde
entfaltet wie ihr richtiges potenzial
wenn nicht werden automatisch alle daten
aller sense boxen gesammelt und in die
opernfans web übertragen
auf der open text sieht man erst mal
viele makler ja die rund um deutschland
weil wir tatsächlich in deutschland
gefördert vom bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung und man erkennt
dort stationen die diese marke eben
darstellen und man sieht grüne markt ist
natürlich gerade live die live daten
liefern kriegt man diese marke an
nimmt man die einzelnen phänomene die
gemessen werden also temperatur
luftfeuchte oder andere dinge
und man sieht nichts kleine kurve die
eben die daten der letzten tage zeigt
von denen soll man die da so schön dass
es in der nacht zum beispiel tees als
tagsüber hier bei uns in deutschland
das sieht man auf der karte und kann
dort seine boxen registrieren kann auch
ein bisschen mit den spielen bei
interpolation machen aus den daten also
farbverläufe nachstellen
die eben die wände daten und das ist
dann wirklich greifen die bei welchen
leuten im garten stehen ja und ich weiß
wie viel bei wir vielleicht auch ein
garten fliegt halt machten drei genau
auf meinen balkon zu sagen da ist
natürlich auch eine und das kann man
doch gesehen
man ist insoweit anonym an bewegung
nahmen dahinter man kann sich wirklich
anonym seine fans burg registrieren
im moment gibt es über 300 wird durch
aktive boxen in deutschland und die
produzieren heute schon eine beachtliche
menge an daten die von jedem genutzt
werden können
für diese leistung erhielt das projekt
sensburg sogar den febit innovation
award für digitales lernen und lehren
jetzt ob das team dass sich das netz der
aktiven fans boxen weiter verdichten
wird
denn durch die wetterforschung lernen
wir mehr darüber wie unsere umwelt
funktioniert zu lernen wie genau
gewitterzellen entstehen hilft dabei
gefahren früher zu erkennen
das wissen wo sich in der schlacht
besonders viel feinstaub befindet kann
helfen unsere umwelt sauberer zu
gestalten und mehr daten aus allen ecken
deutschlands helfen und das wetter
genauer vorherzusagen
an